[Musik]
ein wunderschöner Morgen
erwartet uns hier in unserer kleinen
süßen skyblock-welt meine Damen und
Herren und wenn in dieser heutigen
Episode alles gut klappt und der
Minecraft Gott der irgendwo da oben
sitzt ein bisschen auf unserer Seite ist
dann werden wir am Ende dieser Episode 7
challenges geschafft haben von daher
verlieren wir gar nicht lange Zeit ich
habe alles schon vorgebaut und getestet
in meiner Skyblock mit Luca testwelt und
es sollte machbar sein es sollte möglich
sein von daher müssen wir ein bisschen
durchziehen also zuallererst machen wir
hier jeden zweiten Block zu einem
Farbblock also zu besamt im Boden bzw
jetzt noch nicht besamten Boden aber zu
fruchtbaren Boden sagen das mal so ich
kann aber eben ganz kurz wenn ich hier
schon eben bin dass hier ab ernten die
süßbären danke auch noch mal für den
Tipp mit denen das klappt echt super ähm
die Sache ist allerdings dass wir dort
vorne
trippieskerne anpflanzen werden und ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich hä warum
Kürbiskerne er gibt doch gar keinen Sinn
Kürbisse kannste kannst du nichts mit
Essen oder der gut ich kann man kann so
Kürbiskernen Kürbiskuchen kann man
glaube ich machen aber darum geht's gar
nicht wir benötigen nämlich die Kürbisse
für Kürbis Laternen das ist wirklich
eine Challenge die wir schaffen müssen
ihr findet die Challenges ja unten
eingeblendet in den in der
Videobeschreibung hier von jedem Video
oder könnt auch auf die Skyblock äh
Website einfach mal gehen du bist
Laternen sind einfach leuchtende
Kürbisse und davon sollen wir zehn Stück
hinkriegen leider ist es mit Kürbissen
nicht so einfach möglich wie
beispielsweise mit Weizen dass man
einfach sagen kann hey guck mal zack
zack zack ausgewachsen Ende ab ernten
oder wie mit einem Baum wenn er dann weg
zack okay gehört mir
sondern wir müssen warten bis sie die
ersten Kürbisse wachsen und das machen
wir auch wir haben hier vorne auch noch
einen Kürbiskern da ging es ein bisschen
schneller den können wir dann
tatsächlich auch direkt neben reinpacken
haben vier neue Kürbiskerne und können
die hier vorne anpflanzen Bam Bam Bam
und BAM und können auch mit dem
Wassereimer hier alles erstmal so ein
bisschen schöner und ausgeglichener
machen bei unserer Farm das hier ist die
erste Challenge um die ich mich jetzt
hier gerade so ein bisschen kümmere bzw
den Satz setze den Anfang liege keine
Ahnung wie man es genau nennt ich nehme
mal ganz kurz diesen Kürbis hier wieder
und setze hier noch mal eben kurz
Kürbiskerne hin so nehmen wir den Rest
des anderen bauen jetzt so jetzt können
wir hier auf jeden Fall erstmal warten
hier setzt sich Weizen in der Mützen
schöner Abschluss ist mit diesem Feld
hier vorne und hier vorne setzt sich
auch mal ganz kurz das weg und das und
pflanzt auch hier Kürbisse an denn ich
möchte wirklich heute alles schaffen und
da möchte ich nicht lange Zeit verlieren
gewachsen nee
das ist genauso wie wenn man damals so
ein Spiel spielen wollte und man dachte
sich sowas lädt voll lang aber wenn ich
weg gucke dann will ich es eh nicht mehr
spielen dann Blitz bestimmt schneller
und guckt mal wieder hin
wäre schön wenn jetzt ein Kürbis
tatsächlich gewachsen wäre ist
allerdings leider nicht naja wir kümmern
uns allerdings direkt um die nächste
Challenge meine Damen und Herren und
zwar ist es tatsächlich eine Challenge
wo wir gar nichts machen müssen denn es
ist ein Nachtrag vor zwei Folgen habe
ich dieses Bett hier vorne gebaut ich
habe es erst da unten gesetzt dann haben
wir allerdings realisiert dass wir immer
nur auf diesem komischen grünen Bereich
geschlafen haben und dann habe ich nach
oben verschoben als ein bisschen
schöneres und vor allem überdacht weil
ab und zu sollte regnen bei Skyblock mit
Luca ja das war tatsächlich auch eine
Challenge ein Bett zu craften also
diesen Nachtrag haben wir dann
tatsächlich auch fertig ich habe vorhin
schon im Augenwinkel gesehen dass da
vorne ein weiterer Kürbis gewachsen ist
den werde ich jetzt behalten weil
weitere Kürbiskerne werde ich glaube ich
nicht anpflanzen und der Kürbis wird
sich direkt mal schön hier in die Kiste
bewegen woraus wir uns die Birken
Setzlinge nehmen meine Damen und Herren
und noch so ein paar
denn eine weitere Challenge die sich
tatsächlich den einmal pack ich mal
lieber hier rein bevor ich irgendwie
sterben sollte soll auch ab und zu
passieren eine weitere Challenge die
sich auch in den challenges auf der
Skyblock Website befunden hat lautete 50
Birkenstämme abbauen
ich weiß nicht wer sich diese challenges
ausdenkt oder wer sich denkt ja das ist
eine gute Idee aber wir akzeptieren es
einfach mal und ihr seht auch schon dass
ich hier gerade fleißig Birken hinsetze
und äh die hier aber mal ganz kurz eben
händisch ach guck mal da haben wir
direkt einen neuen witzigen können wir
direkt hier wieder hinsetzen ähm ihr
seht schon dass ich gerade fleißig
Birkenstämme zerstören bin denn 50
Birkenstämme werden wir auf jeden Fall
auch schaffen frag Dich jetzt
wahrscheinlich eh Luca warum setzen nur
nicht sich den nächsten setzen da vorne
hin wo gerade die Birke stand sondern
hier und den nächsten das wird jetzt
auch wahrscheinlich fragen hierhin ist
sie ganz einfach daran weil ich nur so
wenig Setzlinge habe dass ich jetzt
nicht alle ineinander setzen möchte und
dann riskieren möchte wenn ich jetzt
wieder hinsetzen ich zeige euch mal
einmal ganz kurz der wechselt genau hier
wieder in die Blätter rein das heißt
wenn nicht das Doppelte am Blättern
sondern genau die gleiche Anzahl und die
Chance verringert sich dadurch nur dass
wir pro setzen indem wir schon haben
weitere Setzlinge bekommen deswegen habe
ich den jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen verteilt hingesetzt also das
war auf jeden Fall der zweite Kürbis
haben ist hier vorne einer
hintergefallen ja den können wir auf
jeden Fall auch direkt hier vorne mal
wieder hinsetzen bauen diesen Baum und
Bau noch hier die Birken direkt wieder
ab ich weiß auch noch dass wir glaube
ich sieben Birkenstämme auf der Insel
dahinten abgebaut haben von der schaue
ich mal eben kurz in die Kiste ja sieben
Stück haben wir hier noch 42 das heißt
wir müssen nur noch acht Stück abbauen
das sollte relativ fix gehen müssen wir
noch eben schauen dass hier ein Setzling
irgendwie vielleicht runter droppt hier
kommt aber gar nichts runter weil das
nehme ich hier mit dem Holz verbunden
ist da müssen wir auch nachher aufpassen
dass nichts hier wirklich irgendwie mit
Holz verbunden ist weil ich persönlich
wirklich finde ach guck mal perfekt ich
persönlich finde das Birken die
hässlichsten Bäume in Minecraft sind
deswegen will ich die nicht auf meiner
eh schon nur so kleinen Insel auch noch
stehen haben wir haben 47 Stück also
hier werde ich auf jeden Fall keinen
Baum mehr Pflanzen weil das hier
natürlich alles aus Holz ist und dann
nichts die spawnen das hier oben machen
wir auch weg ach nee guck mal geht schon
weg glaube ich ne haben wir hier auch
noch mal direkt einen Setzling den ich
jetzt direkt nach vorne setzen mehr das
heißt
nichts mehr kommen sollte und wir
irgendwann noch mal Birken benötigen
haben was auf jeden Fall am Start 49 und
[Musik]
haben wir auch diese Challenge geschafft
meine Damen und Herren von daher ganz
schnell die Birken wieder abbauen hier
ist nichts mit Holz verbunden das heißt
die sollte komplett die spawnen hier ist
die leider mit der Eiche verbunden
deshalb wird das hier auch mal eben kurz
trennen werden und jetzt hier auch alles
die spawnen sollte
hoffenlich ja okay geht kaputt hier ist
auch ein weiterer Kürbis gewachsen
nämlich auch direkt mit und das hier
ernte ich auch noch mal eben kurz ab das
wirklich praktisch mit diesem falsche ne
guck mal hier noch ein weiterer Kürbis
den packe ich auch mal eben ganz kurz
hier rein ist runtergefallen nee haben
wir eine Hand so die 50 Birkenstämme gar
keinen Plan was ich damit machen soll
allerdings werde ich einfach mal hier in
die Kiste packen Verstärker und so kann
man das ja immer ganz gut gebrauchen ich
habe auch keine Spitzhacke mehr von
daher werde ich mal einmal ganz drei äh
Bruchsteine abbauen
UNO ist verbrannt perfekt Nummer das
haben wir also Numero Uno dann quasi
numerodos und numero
press dann können wir uns auch noch mal
eben fixed wie viele Birken Setzlinge
auf einmal droppt mir richtig viel aber
zu Beginn des Projekts weiß noch was wir
für ein struggle hatten mit Eichen
Setzlingen aber das ist mir auch schon
in der letzten Folge aufgefallen wir
werden gar nicht so krass aufgeschmissen
gewesen weil es ja tatsächlich auf jeder
Insel hier irgendwie Erde und vor allem
Bäume also dementsprechend auch Holz gab
aber gut meine Damen und Herren haben
wir die Birken Setzling Challenge auf
jeden Fall auch geschafft machen wir
direkt weiter mit der nächsten Challenge
und zwar seht ihr schon ich habe vier
Fichten Setzlinge Erde habe ich am Start
eine Spitzhacke habe ich in der Stadt in
der Hand und ich brauche mal ganz kurz
das hier eben ab denn der ein oder
andere wird sich schon denken was ich
jetzt machen werde und wird sich
vielleicht aber auch Fragen Luca das hat
doch gar nichts mit den challenges zu
tun vier Fichten Setzlinge
ich kann euch mal ganz kurz erklären an
alle die keine Ahnung von Minecraft
haben was man mit vier fichtensetzlingen
nebeneinander machen kann damit kann man
den größten Baum einfach so erschaffen
den es in Minecraft gibt und zwar die
Riesen Fichte
ihr wisst ich liebe Fichten ich liebe
Fichtenholz ich liebe alles was mit
diesem Material zu tun hat deswegen ist
mein mein Haus primär aus Fichten ihr
seht doch schon die Zäune im Hintergrund
sind aus Fichten und alles einfach auch
in Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 was
irgendwie Leute zu tun hat habe ich
versucht mit Fichtenholz zu bauen
deswegen liebe ich eigentlich wirklich
Fichten aber diese Riesen Fichte hasse
ich weil das einfach so ein Baum ist
ohne Struktur das ist ähm wie diese
ganzen Neubau Häuser meine Eltern wohnen
selber in so einem Ding deswegen ist es
ein bisschen in safe ist aber ich sag
das jetzt nicht so schön wenn dieses
sterile und ich weiß ich habe selber
eine relativ clean eingerichtete Wohnung
aber trotzdem mit Liebe und Wärme so
über so Holz am Boden und blabla und
diese Fichte erinnert mich immer an so
komm wir ziehen mal einen Baum hoch so
ein künstlichen Baum bisher wie ich
meine das sieht ja auch gleich wenn ich
den Pflanze und wenn ich meine
riesenpflicht wenn ich sage riesen
Fichte dann meine ich wirklich auch
riesen Fichte wir werden den nämlich
hier vorne hin bauen das hier werde ich
abbauen und werde hier vorne auch noch
mal eben kurz ah die Stufen habe ich
jetzt gar nicht ich habe ja normale
Bruchsteine abgebaut und keine Stufen
und mir direkt mal nach oben und machen
uns ein paar Stufen sollten 12 reichen
ich weiß nicht wann man noch ein paar
mehr noch mal insgesamt
18.4 Erde habe ich am Start die habe ich
am Start und bauen den habe ich auch am
Start sollte also alles klappen denn
noch wenn ihr sowas noch nicht gesehen
habt in Minecraft dann äh haltet euch
fest dieser Baum wird gigantisch also
hier vorne hier vorne und auch hier und
hier welche hin dass wir von jeder Seite
das ganze komplett gesichert haben zack
ich setze hier noch mal zwei Jahre hin
hier Fichten drauf wir nehmen unser
Knochenmehl
das ging fix
das ging wirklich fix in der Monsterfarm
ist wieder Party und meine Damen und
Herren
diese Riesen Fichte wenn ihr die noch
nicht gesehen habt in Minecraft haltet
euch fest ich drehe mich jetzt um
die ist einfach mal höher als unsere
Monsterfarm
man sieht die Spitze nicht mal von hier
also dieser Baum ist wirklich irre oh es
ist Nacht das heißt ich gehe mal ganz
schnell direkt schlafen wir haben auch
hier ein wunderschönen Ausblick auf den
Sonnenaufgang bzw auf den Mondaufgang
erstmal
[Musik]
Luca Staffel 1 wo wir auch aus dem
Fenster von unserem Haus rausgucken
konnten und genau diese Himmelsrichtung
hatten ähm um zu sehen dass dort die
Sonne aufgeht im Westen geht glaube ich
die Sonne aus im nee im Osten geht sie
auf im Süden ist sie am höchsten nimmt
sie ihren Lauf und im Westen jetzt
runtergehen und im Norden ist
tatsächlich nie zu sehen so ich habe
immer ganz kurz meine steinacks und Bau
noch mal eben kurz hier die Melone ab
melonenfarm habe ich gerade das ich
mitbekommen sehr sehr cool und ich
brauche noch mal hier vorne den Kürbis
ab den nehme ich direkt mal eben mit und
diesen Kürbis nehme ich mir auch mit
hier vorne sind alle Blätter die Spawn
das ist auf jeden Fall sehr sehr gut und
hier vorne ist auch alles dies und die
Melone nämlich auch noch mal eben kurz
mit ganzen Melonen packe ich hier mal
rein
Kürbissamen insgesamt sieben ich liegt
immer hier dass wir die nicht aus den
Augen verlieren Kürbiskerne da weiterhin
rein Knochen brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
noch naja gut ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich Luca warum hast du jetzt
diesen riesigen Baum hier überhaupt
gebaut naja die Sache ist dass ich den
eigentlich nicht brauche dieser Baum ist
wirklich komplett unnötig um eine Aktie
gleich kaputt das heißt muss mir sofort
eine neue machen deswegen werde ich ihn
noch wahrscheinlich wieder abbauen das
wird allerdings ein bisschen dauern da
werde ich euch gleich noch mal timelapse
einblenden jedoch benötigen wir das auf
dem der Baum gewachsen ist und der
andere Noob so wie ich es auch weil ich
habe tatsächlich auch erst vor dieser
Aufnahme meiner testwelt erfahren und
herausgefunden äh der ein oder andere
Anfänger von Minecraft wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich denken luca du hast doch
der Erde hingesetzt wenn es jetzt wieder
abbaut dann ist er doch auch wieder Erde
nein
ihr seht schon das hier ist normale Erde
und das hier ist das was dieser Baum uns
gibt nämlich Pott Soul heißt das es
könnte auch ein Name sein von irgend so
World of Warcraft Spieler oder Name von
so einem richtig verranzten Club an der
Hamburger Reeperbahn aber Pott soll ist
tatsächlich das Material was sich hier
befindet ich baue mich jetzt mit Erde
drauf dann seht ihr schon passiert
nichts wenn ich einen podzill Block
allerdings abbaue seht ihr schon kommt
er raus
von daher verschwenden wir tatsächlich
keine Erde weil auf pottsohlen da kannst
du jetzt nicht irgendwie weiß ich nicht
näherbaren Boden raus machen oder den zu
keine Ahnung was verwandeln wir
verschwenden keine Erde denn wenn wir
das wieder abbauen haben wir eh ganz
normale Erde allerdings benötigen wir
mindestens einen podolblock für die
Challenge
riesenmaschhrun wir haben ja dort hinten
von der Insel ein paar Pilze mitgenommen
ein paar braune Pilze in paar rote Pilze
und wir müssen uns insgesamt 10
pilzsuppen machen ich weiß noch nicht
genau wie wir das hinkriegen sollen wir
dafür braucht man glaube ich eine
Pilzfarm wenn ihr wisst wie man sowas
baut schreibt gerne unten in die
Kommentare ich habe nicht ein bisschen
recherchiert über Youtube geschaut und
es dauert wirklich ewig bis das wächst
also das so lange möchte ich das Projekt
jetzt auch nicht haben ehrlich gesagt
dass wir da jetzt irgendwie ein Jahr
lang warten müssen ja die ersten Pilze
wachsen das ist nichts was man irgendwie
mit Knochenmehl beschleunigen kann oder
so leider oh dieser Baum ist ja so
riesig ne also das ist ja wirklich
unfassbar jetzt nicht gedacht dass wir
uns doch so lange hoch bauen die Sache
ist allerdings dass wenn man Pilze
anpflanzen möchte man ein gewisses
lichtlevel benötigt und damit meine ich
nicht wie bei Tieren wenn die spawnen
sollen oder wenn Bäume spawnen sollen
dass man irgendwie möglichst helles
lichtlevel benötigt sondern bei Pilzen
tatsächlich ein möglichst dunklen Raum
und entweder gab es die Möglichkeit dass
ich unter meine Insel eine Art Keller
baue unter Licht Level 3 sie muss das
Ganze sein mal kurz zur Info hier bei
Tageslicht haben wir vielleicht nicht
Level 15 oder so ey da ach guck mal hier
ist endlich Ende haben wir vielleicht
nicht Level 15 oder so das heißt wir
müssen schon deutlich tiefer gehen auch
Nacht reicht nicht aus also bei Nacht
kannst du auch keine Pilze bauen es muss
wirklich stockfinster sein also es muss
ein komplett abgedunkelter Raum sein
dann haben wir wiederum das Problem dass
dort auch Creepers bauen können oder
beispielsweise Zombies von daher habe
ich mich ein bisschen schlau gemacht und
habe überlegt auf was kann man denn
vielleicht noch
Pilze draufsetzen guck mal wir sind
wirklich auf der Höhe von der
Monsterfarm ist ja unfassbar dieser Baum
auf was kann man noch Pilze draufsetzen
und da kam mir tatsächlich Portfolien in
den Sinn bzw habe ich auch durch Youtube
Video herausgefunden denn potsohl ist
tatsächlich so
ausgestattet dass man einfach einen Pilz
nehmen kann den da drauf setzen kann und
dann äh
ignoriert der Pilz irgendwie das Licht
Level also wir schauen einfach mal ganz
kurz hier in die in die Kiste wir müssen
das nämlich auch nur mit dem roten Pilz
machen und nicht mit dem nicht mit einem
braunen Pilz oder so wir nehmen unser
Knochenmehl und können tatsächlich den
roten Pilze draufsetzen und ein
[Musik]
wir haben es geschafft Leute wir
tricksen zwar ein bisschen rum hier mit
den challenges aber es ist möglich und
hier kommen tatsächlich neue Pilze raus
das heißt wir benötigen keine pilzfarben
merke ich sogar gerade weil wir einfach
ganz viele von diesen Pilzen erschaffen
können und das bleibt sogar Pott so das
heißt wir müssen keinen weiteren
riesigen Baum mehr schaffen
dementsprechend schaffen wir es
eventuell sogar heute das noch mit den
zehn pilzsuppen hinzukriegen hey das ist
ja ihre was das heute für eine Folge ist
ich habe erst ich habe noch gar keinen
Cup gemacht glaube ich sogar tatsächlich
ey das ist ja wirklich irre ey sorry
Leute ich bin wirklich begeistert von
diesem Projekt von uns einfach von mir
kann man ja immer so sagen meine Idee
alles und youtube hat mir dabei auch ein
bisschen geholfen ich habe wirklich
wieder vor der Folge eine Stunde rum
recherchiert wie ich das hier alles
mache und wie ich die Folge Aufbau und
so also ich hoffe euch gefällt das
Projekt ich versuch's wirklich sehr sehr
cool zu machen ich weiß und das sehe ich
auch immer in den Kommentaren nichts
kann mit Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1
mithalten das weiß ich selber und da
wird auch nie wieder was kommen jede
Folge hat einfach siebenstellige Aufrufe
jede Folge fast das ist krank und was
auch krank ist ist dass wir elf Kürbisse
am Start haben von daher auch die
nächste Challenge abschließen können und
zwar
da muss ich gleich noch mal schauen
allerdings soll uns das auch nicht
jucken denn wir können uns erstmal um
den Pilz hier vorne ähm und werden dann
tatsächlich auch direkt den roten äh den
braunen Pilz auch noch mal anpflanzen um
uns auch dort schön die an ganzen
anderen Pilze zu krallen wir brauchen
nämlich insgesamt zehn von jedem Pilzen
hier auch noch mal eben kurz zack den
braunen Pilz nehmen den können wir jetzt
auch direkt anpflanzen und dann sollten
wir direkt einen Risiken wie schnell das
hier geht ein riesigen von denen hier
rausbekommen und hier oben kommen da
Pilze raus ich glaube nicht ne irgendwie
bei dem Braun kommt nichts
doch da kommen auch braune Pilze raus ey
das ist ja der absolute Knaller meine
Damen und ich bin wirklich absolut happy
einfach nur wie krank das gerade
funktioniert alles klappt bisher in der
Folge aber es war auch irgendwie logisch
dass jetzt irgendwie mal ein bisschen
was vorwärts gehen muss weil diese Folge
mit der Monsterfarm bist du noch wo die
dreimal explodiert ist und dann wurden
Creeper oben in die Luft geflogen ist
und ich bin gestorben und so da ist so
viel schief gelaufen dementsprechend
muss einfach mal ein bisschen was
klappen ich lass mal zur Sicherheit zwei
podolblöcke hier das sieht doch alles
nicht so schön dass das werden wir dann
in der nächsten Folge alles machen ich
lass mal zur Sicherheit zwei Portion
Blöcke damit wir noch ein bisschen Pilze
da irgendwie wieder anbringen können und
jetzt werde ich mir erstmal aus dem
ganzen Holz was wir gemacht haben schöne
planks machen BAM und daraus nicht Boote
sondern Schüsseln wir brauchen sogar nur
ganz wenig nämlich nur insgesamt zehn
Stück die packe ich jetzt hier hin dann
nehmen wir unsere braunen Pilze den
roten habe ich hier unten leider wieder
reingelegt nehmen den roten Pilze auch
noch mal ganz kurz raus und packen die
jetzt einfach übereinander hier rein
roter Pilz brauner Pilz und haben ach
die kann man ja nicht decken so die muss
man jetzt einzeln nehmen hier fünf sechs
sieben acht neun
haben wir auch die Zehn pilzsuppen
geschafft
ich bin voll
ach so warte da muss ich jetzt mal ganz
kurz eben was sichern so meine Damen und
Herren ich habe jetzt gerade mal ein
bisschen was aufgeräumt und einsortiert
und äh habe auch gerade mal gegoogelt
warum das mit diesem Kürbissen nicht
klappt ich kann auch tatsächlich das
hier alles mal eben kurz wieder abbauen
denn wir haben auf jeden Fall genügend
Kürbisse die Sache ist dass das
geschnitzte Kürbisse sein müssen die man
auf die Kürbislaternen die man für die
Kürbis Laternen braucht weil das ja dass
der Kürbisse sein müssen die so ein Loch
drin haben und um einen Kürbis zu
schnitzen muss man ihn hin platzieren
und dann leider
mit einer Schere Rechtsklick machen auf
den Kürbis und für eine Schere benötigt
man Eisen und das benötigen wir das
haben wir leider nicht von daher
schreibt mir bitte bitte bitte in die
Kommentare wie ich das hinkriege mit mit
dem Eisen damit ich endlich mal Eisen
bekomme die Sache ist allerdings dass
ich ja gesagt habe wir schaffen heute
sieben challenges und das kriegen wir
auch hin weil mit diesem pilzsuppen
damit hätte ich gar nicht gerechnet für
heute weil ich dachte wir brauchen eine
Pilzrahm weil ich nicht dachte dass so
ein Pilz den man spawnt auch Pilze
abwirft aber ist ja irgendwie auch
logisch von daher schaffen wir
tatsächlich wirklich die sieben
challenges wir haben bisher geschafft
Bett craften Birkenstämme abbauen und
den Giant red mushroom das heißt es
fehlen noch vier
eine davon können wir direkt hier machen
und zwar das Zuckerrohr nehmen und dann
das Zuckerrohr einfach mal hier
hinsetzen
das ist eine Challenge
eine zuckerrohrfarm
ich weiß das ist jetzt nicht so eine
Farm ist wie hier vorne aber das sogar
wächst da vorne und dementsprechend ist
es eine Farm also wir haben pilzsuppen
geschafft zuckerfarben 50 Birkenstämme
Bett und giant red mushroom also den
großen roten Pilz dementsprechend machen
wir noch zwei challenges für die erste
Challenge benötigen wir ob sie die an
von daher weiß der ein oder andere
wahrscheinlich schon was wir machen
werden und zwar das höllenportal ich
werde das potsohlen ich habe vorhin
gesagt ich werde jetzt hier lassen
allerdings brauchen wir nichts mehr mit
Pilzen wir haben die pilzsuppen und wir
haben den großen Pilz erschaffen jetzt
wirklich einfach mal abbauen weil genau
hier ist so ein wunderschöner Platz für
unser höllenportal deswegen ähm werde
ich mal eben fix hier alles vernünftig
machen damit es auch schön aussieht hier
nehme ich einen hin und dann hier ob sie
dann hier wir dürfen uns nicht verbauen
denn sonst
klappt das ganze nicht wir können
nämlich den Obsidian Block dann nicht
wieder abbauen weil man dafür eine
diamantspitzhacke benötigt und wir alle
wisst haben wir keine Diamanten hier an
der Seite geht's nämlich hoch zack zack
zack zack hier kommt eine
bruchsteinstufe rauf und hier geht's
auch drei hoch zack zack zack ich habe
keine bruchsteinstufen mehr
dementsprechend werde ich noch mal eben
fix hochgehen und mir welche machen BAM
6 Stück sollten ausreichen denn auf die
andere Seite kommt auch noch mal ein
Bruchstein drauf kann ich von jetzt
elegant einmal kurz so machen und dann
kommen hier Zack und zack das ist unser
höllenportal
ihr seht wir haben es geschafft es ist
dort es ist allerdings noch nicht an da
bin ich nämlich auch auf eure Hilfe
angewiesen wie genau kriegen wir das
Ding jetzt aktiviert ich habe kein
Feuerzeug für ein Feuerzeug benötigt man
Eisen und ein Feuerstein und das Problem
ist dass ich weder ein Feuerstein habe
noch Eisen bei 5 Feuerstein benötige ich
gravel ich weiß nicht ob es irgendein
Workout mit Lava vielleicht gibt äh wenn
ihr da irgendwas genaueres wisst
schreibt es mir auch bitte unten in die
Kommentare trauriges ich kann ja leider
wirklich gerade nicht auf Tipps
zugreifen weil seine vorproduzierte
Folge für meinen Urlaub ist
dementsprechend ging die letzte Folge
Skyblock mit Luca für mich noch gar
nicht online gerade in meiner Zeit
Rechnung und ich muss ja noch ein
bisschen abwarten ich nehme auch mal
ganz kurz meine fichtenzäune und äh
grenzt das hier ein bisschen schöner ab
wir müssen auch wirklich schreibt mir
das auch mal gerne unten in die
Kommentare mit dem sie uns irgendwas
anderes überlegen klar sieht schön und
ulkig aus so ein bisschen aber es ist
jetzt nicht so irgendwie ich sage ja
total schön aber auch schon dass das
jetzt hier so ist
komm wir machen es ein weiter nur einen
weiter nebenan dass wir hier einen einen
Platz haben zum rumlaufen weil ich mag
es nicht wenn sich diese Zäune damit
verbinden also das hier wieder alles
mitnehmen hier vorne hier vorne hier
vorne und auch diese Blöcke abbauen
hoffentlich kriege ich die nee kriege
ich nicht
nee kriege ich nicht perfekt
ich nicht super und dem werde ich
wahrscheinlich auch nicht kriegen Klasse
der war wieder super funktioniert so
brate ich halt kurz noch mal meine
letzten Bruchsteine zu 18 Bruchstein
Stufen so dass wir es jetzt auf jeden
Fall hinkriegen sollten hier alles ein
weiter nach nebenan zu setzen also auch
dich abbauen und dich hier vorne auch
abbauen und den tatsächlich auch abbauen
also hier vorne Bam Bam Bam und dann
hier zack zack zack zack zack zack
und zack und da drauf jetzt ganz
entspannt die Steinziegel 1 2 3 4 5 und
die Fichtenholz Zäune zack zack zack
eine Fackel in die Ecke und dann haben
wir auch das hier ein bisschen schöner
am Start hier noch eine drauf
bis wann hat das Portal anzünden das
schöne ist auch dass es jetzt
tatsächlich hier vorne stehen haben und
nicht hier irgendwie auf unserer Insel
weil das macht immer so ein paar
Geräusche allerdings war das Challenge 6
von 7 und wir kommen direkt zur letzten
Challenge fürs heutige Video meine Damen
und Herren dann war es tatsächlich
glaube ich das Video wo ich am wenigsten
geschnitten habe allerdings äh haben wir
trotzdem dafür eine Menge geschafft die
Challenge die ich nämlich als letztes
machen möchte ist eine Angel eins zwei
drei zack eine Angel und wir werden
jetzt einfach ein bisschen in unserem
See angeln zum Ende des Videos
[Musik]
und damit haben wir die letzte Challenge
auch geschafft meine Damen und Herren
die Sonne es ist wieder der perfekte
Zeitpunkt die Sonne geht gerade unter
ihr habt ja gerade die timeless
eingeblendet gesehen falls euch übrigens
fragt warum hier unten nur neun Fische
sind hier ist noch ein hoher Lachs
hinten in der Ecke gewesen von daher
sieben rohe Kabeljau zwei Kugelfische
und äh ein Rohr Lachs ich esse kein
Fleisch oder Fisch in Minecraft von der
schmeiße ich die tatsächlich alle wieder
rein in den Teich ich weiß äh die
schwimmen jetzt eh nicht so toll rum
aber sollte wir tun einfach so als ob
die jetzt hier ihr Highlight Leben und
mir den Sonnenuntergang anschauen denn
ich will an der Stelle die heutige
Episode beenden 7 challenges haben wir
in der heutigen Folge geschafft wir
haben das Bett gekauft schon vor zwei
Folgen aber das war der Nachtrag wir
haben eine Zuckeraufnahme erstellt die
zwei kleines aber sie funktioniert wir
haben 50 Birkenstämme abgebaut wo ich
den Sinn auch immer nicht so ganz
verstehe wir haben eine riesigen guten
Pilz erschaffen was ein ziemlicher mit
dieser riesigen Fichte die da erstmal
stand aber wir haben es geschafft
dadurch hatten wir genügend Pilze um uns
10 pilzsuppen zu machen wir haben 10
Fische Gangelt jetzt gerade zum Ende und
das was Sie hier rechts seht ist unser
höllenportal und das werden wir in der
nächsten Folge anzünden ich bin auf eure
Kommentare angewiesen schreibt mir alles
unten voll wie ich das Teil anzünden
kann irgendwie mit einer Lava daneben
wie genau das funktionieren soll weil
ich will wieder die Lava verlieren noch
will ich irgendwas anzünden aber wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weitere
Videos nichts verpassen ich wünsche euch
eine wunderschöne Weihnachtsfeier Zeit
gerade aktuell ich hoffe es war super
toll bei euch an Weihnachten und keine
Ahnung was ich weiß nicht mehr wenn
dieses Video kommt aber auf jeden Fall
dann nach Weihnachten ich muss unbedingt
schlafen es ist 2:30 Uhr und ich bin
wirklich tot
wir sehen uns ich habe euch lieb haut
rein